in the far-flung future in the deepest
reaches of space beyond galaxy numero
uno there is the second galaxy the
galaxy full of $1 the galaxy full of
danger we replay veeral's
we'll discover what it takes to survive
in this dazzling beautiful thing with us
will we survive pepper 1 it's starting
wait what you already went you got your
name already yeah okay I know I'm gonna
be an engineer wait what what
specialization are you guys here I did
it first but no I'm a scientist no
that's my thing but you can't be the
engineer I'm supposed to be the engineer
literally too late you need to give me a
chance I'm gonna be the third lady over
from the right and I'm gonna be a
soldier all right I'll be the scientist
whatever I hate myself okay here we go
chapter one did you guys give yourself a
custom name or did you take the defaults
my name is it Bob
obviously oh man you guys shut up you
you can you shut up oh never mind
- radio I'm approaching a shipwreck what
are you guys doing I'm scanning a
shipwreck I'm confirming that I'm a
soldier in the the ECD name shut up I'm
playing I'm getting pirate ambushed
pirate pirate pilot says take him down
don't spoil it
unknown signals appearing possibility
it's time the caboose here ooh
select the shipwreck Oh pirates you guys
are literally ruining my life right now
stop smiling I'm getting shot Oh pirate
pirate attack thanks guys for calling it
oh I'm destroying them okey you and then
lock yeah yeah get him
I already killed them combat you know
that's that's surprisingly well done
fire everything why is none of us a
captain one of us needs to be a cabbie
the captain I vote for mark yeah for
Wade because I bet that would be an
interesting captain
I sure will wait the police force
captain just said I have to get it I
earned thirty thousand credits that's
how many credits mark you better start
the warp engine you got to get in here
to the station mark okay so many things
guys you're getting to the station I'm
level two nerds I'm level three I got a
blaster ship hanger mark you gotta go to
the shin stolen my new blaster you've
got to go to the ship I'm already here I
did it alright apparently we're locked
into some sort of tutorial won't get
through it separately together let's do
this I'm back in space I'm starting warp
engine wait if you guys come out to the
dams or you go into the same place that
I am going to the damsel in distress I'm
getting attacked I'm gonna protect I'm
getting attacked we can fix it okay why
didn't I walk I'm a fool auto-lock oh
you can auto ha yes you can auto lock I
can auto fire too apparently dude Auto
combats killer right now well alright
fine I'll Auto combat just straight-up
destroyed
as half as good of a soldier as me my
own combats a much better soldier than
me combat is the best I think I went
into the warp gate I'm going into some
hyper warp gate oh dude it's a rainbow
in here just just behind you guys good
graphics for mobile believe this is a
mobile game yeah I send you a message
with is your message uh appropriate cuz
the whole thing sensor yeah I don't know
your target about men stop for sub I
don't think so um okay I had to restart
the game now we'll never be friends
I am annihilating these pirates all
their families are never gonna see them
again they're just trying to steal from
the rich to give to their families and I
am annihilating everything rich to give
to themself yeah good yeah good dad get
dead pirate wanderer oh you like
traveling uh travel to your grave I'm
chasing down a pirate defense gunnery
unit yeah well I already killed those
people so he you guys you guys need to
get on my level all right fall behind
again well maybe if you were as cool as
me you might actually have something but
I get +5 everything when I'm in space
that's my right
ten points cuz you're you something
happened in this place and everyone
seems to be dead no its parts are about
to be dead never mind I'm killing more
pirates I'm killing pirates first I'm
killing all the Pirates should I kill
them I kill them they're ghosts because
I already killed them there's no pirates
in the they don't exist because I
believe the difference around their base
killing them what are you doing I'm back
their base is just in ashes after what I
did when I looked at them
oh yeah well their base never existed
cuz I thought about destroying I've got
a cutscene that's the explosion of this
base look kill the pirate leader they're
gonna be leaderless that's really this
chapter for why you have to do that well
I mean it's just like you know how
all the people's families are now
leaderless because their parent figures
are now dead because of me because
you're exactly the overarching pirate
but you're amazing
yeah he's a murderer love pipe someone
just called me an [ __ ] I think they
might have been talking to you wait were
they in your house throwing shade across
entire galaxies to reach Wade yeah
exactly that's pretty intense there's a
okay
sidebar there's a lot of cool stuff this
new hangar unlock guys guys I'm level
seven now hey cool horse done doc with
this I thought you were already at the
party mark good morning
no I said it was better damn level nine
now so how's that I'm taking off again
see I don't think you are level nine I
think you're lying to me there's no way
that you're level nine I just went into
the front was level nine mark was level
six and I was able to exactly thank you
I think all of those things are lies and
I'm gonna choke say it it's guaranteed
to be a fat line checking that's 100
percent purity your level seven both of
you who got God
[Music]
I'm getting a license to pilot a
destroyer you guys are gonna you know
guys are gonna wish you could suck me
when you see me in my destroyer I don't
know if that's gonna wish oh these guys
hurt kind of a lot oh these guys kind of
hurt okay maybe the game got hard oh
goodness gracious gravy I don't know
what all my buttons do oh I want to
upgrade my thingies I'll upgrade your
thingy oh I didn't realize that things
cost energy to start oh that's
interesting a little more you know no no
no no I'm just looking at I'm trying to
learn this game you know because I'm
great and you know I I know I know how
things work in games because I yeah
obviously I'm like wait and you sure
sure dude I know everything I do know it
all know literally nothing
screen-recording failed to save what no
how much of it failed the last hour and
20 minutes no you're way over here yeah
cool I'm coming to you guys this is the
first time we're gonna be able to team
up I'm gonna be friends fine leave this
totally is the first actual time finally
I just have to change my shirt out of a
doc this button doc it's kind of like an
arrow going into a hole doc button yeah
it's the doc button actually when I talk
to the doc button holy well you know I
don't like your attitude there buddy
what is the magpie you guys get the
magpie oh I do have a magpie I got to
get a license apparently to get a
license you have to go do a training
mission which is apparently what I'm
doing and I don't know why mark I
believe in you all right let me try to
do this quickly sorry guys just gotta
joy this douche here I think we know who
the douche is yeah you got him wait I
got him you really turned that around on
me really hard
[Applause]
the tables have finally turned on you
boy also you smell glasses like I only
do occasionally and mark only we all are
them dude my vision is perfect you work
contacts wait I'm wearing glasses right
now well that's wrong wrong
well that was a 20-18 wait 2019 wait is
only wrong half the time too cuz you
can't afford price why okay that's too
real but yes you know what I'm actually
gonna go back to a smaller ship because
I want to be more nimble yeah I'm all
nimble and small you guys are never
gonna be able to catch me I'm gonna run
circles around you I caught you I'm here
I'm literally gonna run sir you're
you're a bajillion a you away from me oh
yeah what's this here's my burst engine
I have more fields now so you can't do
close to you what am i near you guys
shut up we don't care
locked on target locked on target
I'm so close to target docking with
target locking with are way bigger than
mine oh wait oh yeah look at that sick
docking all right wait come on pick a
mission let's go leader you're the
leader you invited me
your eye is there a leader I don't even
have leaders the thing I think I got to
go get the same ship as you guys if
we're gonna be able to do things
together are you saying your ship is bad
no my ship is too good actually I'll be
right back okay your ship is in fear
here
no not inferior just it's it's you know
it's it's motion ocean it's ocean motion
is to to impress it was bad no no not
bad so it's bad what do you want what do
you wanna do
yeah Wade lead the way I'm following you
okay so you guys want to do it oh my god
if you go to the galaxy view and zoom
out it's huge
yes it is I mean you guys want to go to
de su ba Henry nothing where is the
Shuba Oh Bob does your game just crash
yeah so I'm gonna go to Glick I think
the far right is our warp jump right
ones an information tab I don't know if
the two on the I don't know if the third
one does yeah the far right is jump to
that one all right so I'm gonna jump in
three two one
Glick here we come all right good job
warped so it's fine I'm at I'm at the
zip zapper yeah hello hey boys how's it
going okay so now that we're in Glick is
there anything to blow up and lift maybe
Bob did you hit go to me as soon as I
said go to you yes oh my god oh man
we've docked oh my god creating a
singularity between ourselves what a
time to be alive dance okay click Space
Station come and come and do it oh we're
at maximum warp and we just warp around
the galaxy together this is really
relaxing I mean pretty much yeah I think
we could just keep going into deeper and
deeper enemy territory until we go
somewhere that we die well what about
the just aurora you guys see aurora it's
just to the the west of us it's that one
little red in the next to the yellow by
way.you yen yeah I see Aurora security
status lawless you guys wanna go there
oh my god Aurora I see it alright we're
going to Aurora looking warp and three
warping - I'm going see you guys and
we're really getting this coordination
down are we gonna have to go through
every gate to get there are we gonna
like I think it tells you no different
warps you have to do yes cool so we got
this four per thousand warps around the
entire universe forever I mean that's
kind of cool I do like things having a
sense of scale and being like if I want
to go all the way over here I have to
jump through all these hoops Oh at least
it automatically goes whoosh yeah I hope
there's no fuel yeah okay just get out
there that's like warp drive pleaded
okay that'd be a pretty quick game over
for us I think I don't think we'd
survive in the lawless territory hype
it's gonna be fine oh what's the worst
that could happen game crashed again why
is the game crashing well at least
you're only a few hundred jumps behind
[Music]
I can't make my voice part that low but
it's not farting boys those are called
boys farts I have had that no oh my god
was that one right then no yes no listen
when you're dis deep and this deep in
space sometimes they re I'm getting the
space stupids so nosy deep in space the
one jump stupids is that what you're
getting up bet it is yeah yeah I've
warped a couple too many times
daddy's coming home alright okay daddy
we're on our final jump right now you
may still have to we'll see you soon
definitely unless we get into Aurora and
it's horrible and we blow up a bajillion
yeah I got time I have to cancel this I
don't know wait this last jump doesn't
seem to reunion you notice that I'm just
sitting here hello
yeah are you uh ship just oh are we
exploring parts of the universe that
we're not to explore unable to enter
this area until pilot level is 19 ball
that was a very long way to travel to
not be able to go in I'm coming anyway
all right then let's let's there's God
I'm going a bajillion miles an hour
let's try and do a Explorer you know if
we can explore in this area here just
tech and do it can we try and encounter
I'm just like scanning for an encounter
yeah I'm scanning for one to escort two
from Vivian I oh I've got investigated
the unknown from investigator Matt level
21 Oh Lord
uh I guess let me try and like trigger
mine war petition now go for it Bob I'm
gonna try to follow you what see with me
whoa Bob you you went away where'd you
go
we're with me where are you uh where'd
you buy em at escort to wingman is
arriving okay I don't see you anywhere
anymore Bob I think you're gone all
right well I'm gonna go try to die with
this level 21 mission I got it literally
said there are enemies that I cannot
defeat at my current level yeah I don't
think they know how good I am at this
game
[ __ ] and they said I couldn't defeat ya
I'm destroying these guys I'm pretty
much absolutely oh whoa I already
defeated my mission I'm just heading
home to collect the reward it sounds
like you had a pretty lame mission uh
yeah it was just like assassinate the
evil emperor and defeat his entire
regime couldn't have been that
impressive if you were able to beat him
oh [ __ ] I think one of my dudes just
exploded this missions kind of intense
maybe I should be paying attention to it
is that the one that really could not
win yeah you just flip flopping around
right now I'm okay for now anyway I got
a warp all the way back down there is so
I'm a dude yeah can you guys bypass all
of the warp gates if you just hit the
HOME key on the top left you might have
to go through everything like I did if
you can just do that oh you can it still
sets you to go through everything
there's no Chiti way to get around the
size of the universe Wade well maybe we
should get some of those super warp
gates put in maybe you can suck it yeah
[Music]
guys
I thought we were on the same team I set
you up and you smashed it out of the
park there I smashed it in two ways yeah
come on guys I think once we get home
uh-huh
we just huddled together and we just
grabbed it the good ways that we
experienced this game together give you
a look if I were a person at home and
they wanted to play this game maybe I
should put your link in the description
below so that any okay could play this
game yeah and play this game
yeah I would I mean I would recommend it
get some friends to play and you guys
could go explore the wormhole and take
out all the Roberts of the universe I
guess and let and let all the Roberts
die because he failed your mission you
know you know the the developers
actually offered me a levelled up ship
to play with I said no man that's what
you sound like
cuz this whole experience of learning it
I never would have been able to
understand the systems that you would
never have comprehended without the
guides and thanks yeah it's really nice
like playing through the early parts
just that you have learned how to equip
your ship the different types of ships
yeah it's really overwhelming whenever
you get into a game at like a high level
and you don't know what you're doing it
is nice it is nice how detailed it is
but yeah it takes a lot to learn this
one has a very high level of
customization and there's just a lot you
can do with different types of ships
different add-ons with ships different
weapons there's a lot going on which is
a good thing but yeah very it could be
very overwhelming if you jump in like at
the end game so it's nice to build your
way up and see hi Wade I'm undaunted in
Boise don't worry wait where are you
going I'm not sure I'm just gonna follow
you you don't know how to fly do you I
do how do I know Hilah slice I'm a
soldier
they just kind of hand them out to us at
that point right right I see they see
how you're good you oh here uh yeah I
know we're just uh and
oh here comes Baja
this game is really fun I think that I
would actually legitimately unbiased ly
recommend this game for anybody out
there if wanted a fun time I definitely
would to continue playing this because
this is one of the few mobile games I
actually enjoy playing this is one I
would choose to play again I must say
one that has multiplayer like this one
does like being able to like just freely
roam around with each other and screw
around like this Plus just going like
being able to be inside each other like
this
yeah special special maybe this isn't
maybe this isn't quite well anybody who
wants to play the link is in the
description below highly recommend it's
very free yeah it's really cool so thank
you everybody so much for watching check
out Bob and weights perspective in the
little description as well and as always
I'll see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]